l attenti ragazzi e benvenuti a questo
mio figlio sono fa vj allora ogni tanto
la sera mi capiti di giocare quindi
amici e alle volte registro queste cose
perché quando registro per il canale
registro nel con secondo gioco con gli
amici gioco per i cazzi miei però
stavolta ho voluto registrare quello che
abbiamo fatto perché è venuto anche
abbastanza carino quindi ve lo lascio
avevi introduco il gioco sarebbe tipo h1
z1 che è un videogioco dove siamo in 150
persone e vincono vince l'ultimo team
che rimane vivo i team sono fatti da tre
persone
quindi gli ultimi tre che rimangono vivi
hanno vinto e siamo andati da dio ma
veramente la diva buona visione
dai basta vedere i miei video a di 20 0
la cosa che sento mega di moustafa
negati negativo è che io avevo le mie
esigenze
mega deal voi nei commenti quanto mi
manca questo fa vigeva dovrà iniziare a
dire la parola mercatini condivido il
tuo punto l'utente la gente non capisce
lei dà diritto di goldman sahcs da
piccolino dai da piccolino 17 anni cine
a casa me lo dicono tutti anche a dei
controlli forza 90 perché mi dite tutti
che sono più piccoli con lui sono 95
tutto cicinho ma si stronzo ma perché
ivy devi passare i miei video quali
problemi allora andiamo per sabotare e
che nessuno lo vuole a tanti ragazzi ma
basta che i capelli ancora si chiamava
baci saziami quadro basta di parlare ci
andiamo facciamo
dear mario io sono piermario vai dove
siete
c'è un nero qui razzista vieni
all'elicottero l'elicottero dure nella
lead ragazzi parti 10 secondi parte
subito domandiamo da wnw nv mi capisce
la bara è stata la madre ma adesso
quanta gente ci parlo tutti ci ammazzino
va bene dai proviamoci proviamo 500 più
forte che abbiamo tutti bene duro dai
cine1 cesa tutti qua sono tutti esco
vado via aiuto hanno trovato una pizza
sono uscito io tra tra vista la posso
difendermi posso difendermi
hai avuto subito morti tutti non spara
la piccionaia dava da fuoco e stato
bello che bella partita
sì sì non c'è nessun nessuno e che
avevamo ludico lega la voti andati al di
sopra di noi guarda trovando l'angolo
rotture della leader venite qua guardami
veder dall'angolo rotture della leader
eccolo wow si può entrare io si può
entrare nell'angolo rotture io entro o
non parlano ma ora non si può entrare si
può entrare con quale faccia tutta
brucia a lui che gravare in piedi dai
piedi sopra ma noi potete gustarvi
l'angolo natura della leader h troppo
[Musica]
lento nel lago fatto entrare nella
lo rotture della linea e dovete urlare
però anche gli zingari potranno gustarsi
non ci hanno pensato basta partiamo
tutti chiari fronti per vincere le
partite pronti allora
nord nordovest spara la spiaggia così
alla circolare n nw non c'è niente c'è
niente porca [ __ ] c'è una casa una
casa in italia nnw c'è una casa di legno
bene come three barsi se vuoi sempre
dall'altra parte la regola del fiume di
ci sarà da questa parte sono caduto su
un trattore abc anche la macchina della
pool a noi diciamo a chiedere pure vero
la prendo io lavo prendete io prendo le
armi che già prima sono morto oggi con
la macchina c'è qualcuno la macchina io
a sei tu dato ti vede attraverso ma
cos'è mettila da attraverso il muro che
sei seduto e vai giù dalla macchina mia
dal mio armi allora io ho trovato una r
vincolate adesso vi in culo una macchina
via po via via via non ce le chiavi che
ha le chiavi sganciate chiavi ma perché
picchiavano mi ha dato concepire
bastardi fermo da chef ma lui non guido
ok mi rifiuto allora lascia la squadra
ha cambiato idea subito perfetto non ci
voglio credere
se esplode rido porca [ __ ] porta
veloce era sempre avanti andiamo più più
resiste vai vai vai vai bene ai
partecipanti possibile 11 10
un'autobomba
vai a controllare pietro sistema deve
controllare a prefetto prendi a gandhi
prendiamo inseribili pompa cazzi suoi
malcapitato allora abbiamo tutti chi
sorpasso ciao ma come cerchietto sei
piani sono una capretta su una capretta
come fai a salire di un agente ecco dati
questo sito dopo che hai mangiato cinese
me lo ricordo ma anche quando mangio la
pasta faccio delle delle scorregge
incredibili
immagino cioè lei feroce del drop che
non è un po questo comportamento ha
bombardato la c'era qualcuno però io non
vedo assolutamente nessuno la via è
libera
dove vogliamo andare andiamoci
bombardamenti occhio o più questa
visione anche la rai da omero nola il
drop lo vedo tecnico era giovanissimo e
quindi niente non ci arriviamo perché ci
sono dei lampioni in mezzo alla strada a
quelli raggiunti per quale motivo detto
tanto ma è nessuno ha detto e cioè il
bombardamento ma porca [ __ ] questo
era vicino sui lampioni hanno rotto
dell'ampio ravioli richiama i
bombardamenti sono più vasti molto più
belli anche più potenti il bombardamento
e oggi come cazzo hai fatto a
sopravvivere come hai fatto a
sopravvivere gli umori anti ha toccato
praticamente sono caduti missili e hanno
fatto il buco dove c'era lui la sagoma
medikit maledetti lo vuoi non so io è da
meno
nel gruppo d grazie grazie
tutti i miei nudo sul cappotto medici
dell'authority dispone cosa vogliono
cosa vuoi come si alza le mani a valvola
da daniele uno come i barboni in fondo
dei barboni dei medici per strada siamo
a fare i [ __ ] e siamo tra i dieci
quello tra i dieci finalisti
siamo salvi questo vorrei attirato per
niente l'attenzione dove sulla collina
se noi siamo visti dieci volte mi chiama
significa che peraltro abbiamo fatto più
casino noi che non lo so stanno
scendendo stanno scendendo l'arago lina
qualora mentre il caso intimi in casa ma
quale casa non esiste non ci sono io lì
se c'è un nord ovest vieni vai stanno
scendendo dalla collina e libere da un
ora e nicolini come ogni cosa non
passano qua sono qua scontro a fuoco
this entry marketing per casa in tre
case in casa per casa
io ce la posso fare vieni qui ora fare
scorro aiuto mi hanno sparato non hanno
preso a grazie mi sarei volevi chiudermi
fuori aiutarsi è successo perché mi
hanno sparato dalla sparando dalle
colline avete chiuso la porta di noi
sono salica un cazzo chiocchio che
stanno guardando anche il finestre vabbè
ognuno dunque libertà 20 io mi metto qua
mi metto qua sulla cucina sulla cucina
tutto tutto in cucina sono come una
donna che vedete in bomba ragazzi
prendete il polpo che sei irrompano
santi rando vieni bagno ma perché ne
impone via vai via di tutti voglio ti
sparo ti ammazzo io ma perché aprisse
tutto scemo ma tu sei un batti 6
rincoglionimento ma perché
ma perché abbiamo in squadra quest'uomo
non dire parlando di brutto ma perché
magari non aprì la porta
sono gli ultimi questi casa va a fuoco
dalla finestra oppure spanò anche dalla
finestra se li battiamo abbiamo
impiegato di non spostarsi andare a sud
sudest mandare sud est si è subito flora
ci metteranno fuori sicuro quindi o ti
aspettiamo l'ultimo proprio ragazzino
per matura per ora
ahi ahi ahi a farfa turno dalla fine
c'era un'altra finestra porca [ __ ] non
ci avevo fatto caso non lo vedo io
raga vincete vincente per il video
perché quale mi sono fatto uccidere uno
vestito di viola
no sono morto arrivati secondi hanno
vinto sia arrivati secondo verso terzi
marca dicevamo propongo un altro peccato
i ragazzi questa era la cosa che avete
visto e siamo forti forti on ammazzati
talmente tanti che abbiamo dovuto dire
basta fa vj esci dal gioco perché se noi
giochiamo più e io li ho accontentati i
ragazzi spero che questo video vi sia
piaciuto cose c'e un momento è un mi
piace anche i vari social che come
descrizione sono sempre state ci vediamo
il prossimo video è da ragazzi